Sir the team is ready for launch it's about time
this is our home then let's fight for it
Wandavision is gonna be a mind-bending and a very
unique story unlike anything you've seen before
Wanda and vision aren't we a fine pair
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision episode 9 finale trailer video
in the post credit scene video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs going into the finale and
i'll explain what kevin feige has said about the
future of scarlet witch and the Wandavision series
about where he stands when it comes to Wandavision
season 2 potential if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be
doing videos for all the marvel disney plus series
falcon and winter soldier is also going to be
starting really soon too so i'll explain the
schedule at the end of the video just to remind
people when everything is coming we also may have
just found out who that special cameo paul bettany
has been hyping up the past couple of weeks is
so careful for spoilers if you have not seen the
Wandavision episodes yet but as you would expect
it wouldn't be marvel without a post-credits scene
so they have another mid-credits scene where you
have tyler hayward and you find out what sword
has been doing this whole time what he's really
been doing and that he's been lying this whole
time about a bunch of stuff that happened in
the past too with wanda we find out that he's had
vision's body this whole time the original version
of vision the one we've been watching so far is
one that was created out of nothingness by wanda
but the way tyler hayward explains it is that
they tried to reassemble vision's body countless
times but nothing worked until they started
playing with wanda's red chaos magic energy
so they used the residual energy from the 80s
stark tech drone that they tried to kill her with
back in episode 5. remember tyler hayward stuck
a warhead on that without telling monica rambeau
and they're going to launch it into the hex and
hope that it just kills wanda and brings the hex
down getting rid of all the other things she's
created and taking everything back to normal
from before she arrived in west view so even
though they're hyping up a battle between wanda's
version of vision and the white vision what tyler
hayward is hoping is that they'll kill wanda
and they'll just get rid of everything with one
fell swoop but as you've seen the past couple of
episodes anytime tyler hayward tries to go off the
rails it only makes things worse so there's this
thing that monica rambeau said that i think is a
big clue one is both the cause and the solution to
their problem another really important clue agatha
hartness also commended wanda for her magic on
autopilot on the outskirts of town like she wasn't
doing anything actively to control that part of
the magic so i think the threat here is the idea
that what if tyler hayward actually did kill wanda
it would not bring the hex down the hex would only
get worse but they really really wanted to flip
the script during this last episode and explain
why he's really the villain of this situation
and why he lied about everything that happened
when scarlet witch came to visit vision's body
a lot of you are also asking about that why did he
say that scarlet witch stole vision's body during
episode 5. they even had it in the recap at the
beginning of the episode when wanda came to visit
vision's body he seemed to know that she had the
ability to possibly bring him back so even though
he couldn't have predicted what would eventually
happen with the hex i think that he was trying to
get her to purposefully mess with his body so that
he could try other things to bring him back online
then much to his chagrin he found out that her red
chaos magic did in fact work so he just kind of
changed the facts at every turn to suit his needs
so that's why he's trying to get rid of wanda now
like i have what i need i don't need wanda anymore
and she's a liability because she'll tell everyone
what really happened so he's really just as much
of a villain as agatha harkness is at this point
i know everybody's kind of wondering who
the bigger big bad is behind agatha harkness
because she has that book of magic book of dark
magic and it has to belong to somebody and when
she says belong to someone i'm not talking about
someone like doctor strange i'm talking about the
larger cosmic entity whose magic is in the book
like if all magic users draw magic from other
entities or other dimensions where is she drawing
that energy from but the other trailer footage of
the finale that we see in her is of vision finally
making it back to scarlet witch them talking about
saving their home like she keeps saying west view
is our home now then you see them inside the home
looking out like you see the pictures behind
them like they're getting ready for a big battle
you actually do see her fire off a couple blasts
of red magic in the street there which seems
like it just happens after this moment here where
agatha hartness walks up with her children in tow
also a lot of you asking about scarlet witch's
new comic book costume like the full-blown scarlet
witch costume yes we actually did see it in the
original poster like you look at all the tvs
and you look during the different decades and you
see her different costumes from the episodes in a
couple of the tvs you actually see that brand new
costume so they showed this to us before episode 1
was released we've been staring at it this whole
time so it's the same costume that she sees when
the mind stone gives her the vision of her future
where she's wearing the full blown costume you
even see her wearing the headpiece too they might
tweak it just a little bit for doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness but i'm assuming that this
is what she would show up in doctor strange 2
looking like when she's not wearing just regular
street clothes in more context for doctor strange
2 as well so agatha harkness calls her this
mythical being that nobody thought existed you've
been using chaos magic wanda and that makes you
the scarlet witch so the way they're explaining
the concept of scarlet witch in the mcu is that
it's a title that's given to a very special person
they did a version of that in the comics a
while ago too originally scarlet witch was
just wanda's code name the whole time like when
she first showed up in the x-men and the avengers
comics and that was just what they called her but
then the last 10 years or so they retconned that
and they gave the idea that the scarlet witch
was just a title that was passed down through
different generations in wanda's mother her true
mother was a version of scarlet witch before wanda
maximoff became scarlet witch remember during
episode 6 the halloween episode she said that
she was going as a sokovian fortune teller and
showed up in the scarlet witch comic book costume
originally elizabeth olsen said the costume was
going to be different and it was going to look
more like a gypsy's costume more like her comic
book mother's scarlet witch costume so i think
that was just meant to foreshadow this twist about
the scarlet witch title being given to different
people across history most of you also probably
connected the dots too so earlier in the series
when darcy is talking about her manipulating
background cosmic radiation and using that like
the infinity stone energy or the same energy
as the infinity stones that was present at the
big bang that's the exact same thing that act of
the harkness is talking about when she's talking
about wanda manipulating chaos magic manipulating
this cosmic background radiation using it to weave
spells they kind of explained that during the dr
strange movie is that people who are weaving magic
inside the mcu are actually just borrowing
energy from different dimensions to do that
so wanda is quote unquote borrowing background
cosmic radiation energy when she's creating
all these things agatha hardness also clarifies
earlier in the episode that she's super powerful
without realizing it like op overpowered if you're
not familiar with that term she's doing very
complex things very easily that it would normally
take someone years of their life to figure out
so they're sort of building up the idea of
how powerful she is before you get to doctor
strange too which makes more sense why they would
cross over why they would team her up with doctor
strange to fight whatever major threat surfaces
in whatever big post credit scene they'll have
for the finale i know everybody's wondering the
finale isn't going to be that long they need like
a two hour finale to wrap up all the story lines
and things they've set up i'm not expecting them
to completely answer every single question but
they will answer most of the big ones about where
all these characters are headed next it is part of
that we'll see some sort of benedict cumberbatch
doctor strange moment that will explain how she'll
just continue her story in the movie which is why
for all of you asking about Wandavision season 2
kevin feige said currently they're not developing
Wandavision season 2 but he said never say never
they could always do a season two at some point
so for those of you asking what does that mean
about vision obviously she's probably gonna
have to say goodbye to the fake version of vision
that she created but what are they gonna do with
the white vision after they defeat him a lot of
you asked if they could combine the fake version
of vision with the white vision and then use that
as a way to effectively bring regular vision back
i guess it's possible but tayunna paris the person
who plays monica rambeau said that it is going to
be a big cry fest in the finale it's going to
be a very sad ending so bringing vision back
for good doesn't feel like a sad ending so i'm not
expecting them to just completely bring him back
also that gets into the idea of her children
like agatha the hardness hasn't told her yet but
i think we'll get that moment in the finale where
she says your children aren't real you made them
out of nothingness the idea being that if the hex
comes down if she takes all this magic away it'll
hurt or kill her children or make them go away
wanda has no idea how any of this works so this is
also where dr strange could come in and help her
out figure out a way for her children to survive
and also getting into the idea of the multiverse
here a nexus being i think also all this talk
about her being this special scarlet witch
character a mythical person gets into the idea of
her being a nexus being which in the comics means
that she's this focal point for the multiverse
she's a being that exists the exact same in every
single universe like it's always this version of
scarlet witch everywhere across the multiverse
whereas for a lot of other characters you go to
alternate realities and you see different versions
of their character or in some realities they died
a long time ago or in some realities they're evil
but her being a nexus being also explains why
she's so powerful she has all this cosmic energy
that sort of flows through her as a focal point
but the nexus is also a physical place in
space it's sort of like the gateway to all
different realities of the multiverse so what i'm
hoping is is when they answer a lot of questions
about act of the hardness book of dark magic
and things go off the rails we'll find out which
cosmic villain is going to try and take advantage
of that and i know a lot of you also asked about
cathode now because they keep talking about chaos
magic and he is the person behind chaos magic in
the mcu he's also one of the elder gods as well i
know everyone's hoping for mephisto or nightmare
i'm kind of leaning towards nightmare at this
point just based on a number of different things
people have said over the years but even if they
don't outright answer that question who is this
big cosmic villain we'll have enough easter eggs
and clues to make a better guess and hopefully
after the Wandavision finale they'll actually make
an announcement like welcome this big actor who's
going to be playing this giant cosmic villain
in doctor strange 2. we were just waiting for
the Wandavision finale so that we didn't spoil
the reveal also big theory that person will wind
up being ralph agatha harkness's husband that she
keeps talking about in all the episodes but we've
never seen why would she keep mentioning him
if he wasn't gonna be a thing for those of you
asking about evan peters as well i also feel like
they're gonna reveal what's going on with senior
scratchy and now i'm actually leaning towards
him being the evan peters character a version
of nicholas scratch which is kind of like her son
from the comics but just a little bit different
inside the mcu he might not wind up being her
son he might just wind up being her familiar and
even though we didn't see monica rambeau during
episode 8 there's a whole idea that her powers
make her resistant to agatha harkness's magic but
a lot of her storyline also dovetails with what's
going on with tyler hayward as well so i feel
like what we're heading for in the finale is
regular vision or wanda's version of vision versus
the white vision but also monica rambeau helping
out with both wanda's fight in agatha harkness and
the fight against white vision i just did a big
video about monica rambeau and how her powers work
why she's one of the most crazy powerful people in
the mcu just based on the way her powers work
so i'll put a link for that in the description
people wondering who is the mystery cameo going
to be in the finale paul bettany had been saying
for the last couple of weeks that there's this
actor that he was really excited to work with
that he wanted to work with his entire life
so people are like who is the actor that paul
bettany loves more than anyone else that he
has not worked with yet before everyone's had
their big theories about huge mcu characters x-men
characters but here's the thing what if the secret
actor that paul bettany was talking about that
he had always wanted to work with was just paul
bettany himself and he was talking about himself
the white version of vision everyone post all your
spider-man pointing memes if this winds up being
true it would be the most epic troll so well done
sir to paul bettany for trolling all of us
this whole time but just to be clear i am
expecting doctor strange to show up in the finale
so technically that would be a really cool cameo
so there are cameos in the finale big avengers
cameos it's just that he's kind of playing with us
with this other thing that he's talking about but
if you have any other big questions about what's
going on heading into the finale just let me
know in the comments and i'll do more falcon and
winter soldier videos too what'll happen though
is there's going to be a bonus episode like a
special behind the scenes episode like they did
for the mandalorian episodes the week after the
Wandavision finale then the week after that is
when falcon and winter soldier starts there was
also some new justice league snyder cut footage
i'll do a video for that tomorrow as well everyone
click here for my full Wandavision episode 8 video
and click here for that special new monica rambeau
photon video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!